it's fabulous i just wish my mom was
alive to see it
you're coming on a scale from one to f9
how grand is this right here
does it puff you up still a little bit
when you see you know something of this
magnet
oh so you're kidding me i mean i'm a
little girl from london
i'm still sort of blown away by it and
honestly to see that is absolutely
extraordinary
my husband gets incredibly excited the
whole family will be out here probably
later on tonight with doing
selfies i love it helen is back as
kickbutt take no prisoners queenie
in the ninth fast film hitting theaters
june 25th
the movie has already grossed over 232
million dollars globally
leading the charge in the big return to
movie theaters
why do you think people really do need
to see this in a movie theater oh for so
many reasons
i mean just the size and the scale and
the sound but much more important than
all of that is the fact that it becomes
a communal
experience you can laugh together you
can shout together you can
yell at you know your appreciation you
can cry if you want to cry
but you know there's nothing like an
audience get the hear break for me would
you darling
[Music]
you finally get to drive a car i'm
flying in this private car
beautiful car is it beautiful oh my god
yes when i asked
vin about this he said don't pull up
there at the stoplight because she'll
dust dude